So let's talk
about what life is.
Buckminster Fuller said
life is anti-entropic.
In the universe, you have the
second law of thermodynamics.
You have entropy everywhere.
Entropy is breaking everything
into its simpler constituents.
Entropy is the playing out of
process, breaking things down.
But then you have this
thing called life.
In this Goldilocks zone,
this phenomenon of life, life
emerges.
It self-organizes.
It's almost like life resides
in a part of the universe that
is self-organizing
towards complexity.
Its complexity bootstraps
on its own complexity.
Single-celled organisms
emerge in the biochemistry
of a planet like the Earth.
It lives in the Goldilocks zone.
These single-celled
organisms clump together
into multicellular organisms.
These multi-celled organisms
eventually become primates.
These primates then get
caught in self-awareness.
They start to self-perceive.
Then these primates start to
imagine future possibilities.
They start planning.
A mind emerges.
A feral minds turns into a
tool, as Kevin Kelly says.
They can then think with
purpose and deliberation.
Then we spill over the creations
of our minds into the tools.
And then we engage in feedback
loops with those tools
to further extend our
creative possibilities.
It's fascinating
because it seems
there's a process of sort of a
self-organization of emergence
that's happening here.
It's like these things
are coming together,
and they're creating
transcendent effects.
They're exhibiting
Minds, brains--
these things seem
to be greater than the
sum of their parts.
It's when you have higher
level order from lower level
organization, this emergence.
When birds enter swarms,
there's no leader,
there's nobody telling
all the other birds
how to get into
these formations.
But it seems to be
self-organizing.
And we know that we
are made of atoms.
Those atoms clump
together into cells.
The cells clump
together into organs.
Those organs are clumped
together into us.
And we create tools, and
we wire each other mind
to mind communication.
We create a gaia global brain.
There's a global
brain itself, part
of the biological global grid,
nervous system of nature.
And those two things
breathing, thinking,
the think stratum
of the universe.
The universe wakes up.